foreign
TS of of you know don't look at the man
behind the curtain like there's a dog
and pony show over here there's oh you
know that anti-Semitism is bad look at
this guy who's an anti-semite when
there's actually a rise in what's in in
the hatred in the genocidal impulses
um just out of you just where you're not
looking just where none of the media are
pointing their their
I don't even know what journalist Point
pens they don't though right like lasers
I killed lasers and that's not it
but uh like like
I don't see the discussion of what
you're talking about and I do see to
some degree a discussion of what I've
seen over in the somewhat similar land
around sex because there are
increasingly a large number of people
um women mostly some men who are saying
this must stop we are we are going
backwards into a land that is um very
very dangerous for girls and women and
we had won these rights we had we had
secured them and and now we are losing
them
um and so you know I do I do see
substantial pushback over in the sort of
the the sex and gender equivalent space
um but I also
see a lot of encouragement of the
insanity and
it's different with with race and with
ethnicity
because the way the media has decided to
understand it is
um is differently confused
but um you know no one no one in the
mainstream media is explicitly
celebrating anti-semitism
but they are implicitly doing so with
their choices they are inviting it yes
now the the sex and gender version of
this maybe it's just sex really yeah um
there's a different story to be told
right
and I think the thing with sex is
I think we
almost perfectly attained this one I
mean that you know it's an optimality
program problem but the point is women
uh women younger women your age and
younger did have an increasingly open
landscape to choose what to do with
their time effort Talent yep life right
so we solved it at that level and I mean
in fact even in you know rad circles for
for a certain class
right like you know middle middle class
and and above I think you know right
well actually this this goes back to an
old point of mine which is that the
discrimination against women
is fundamentally different than
discrimination against different racial
groups because women exist at every
level every class they may not have been
empowered in the highest class but at
the level of whether their interests
gets spoken to but I mean I I think I
think there's an analog a very clear
analogy to be made here like whereas
women exist in equal numbers at all
classes in equal ratios in all classes
uh black people for instance did not do
not right and uh there are many scholars
out there who would say actually
if you're middle class or higher
um black person growing up in America in
the you know 1990s 2000s you had the
opportunities just as if you were a
middle classer or a higher woman growing
up in you know in the 1970s well you
know you you had the opportunities and
continues to manifest differently race
and sex are not the same thing
um however
if you insist as many on the you know
insane left
uh insist on doing I'm not talking about
class at all and pulling and you know
claiming to be all about
intersectionality and all of these
things but never talking about class
you of course find that black people
have worse outcomes and then you
conclude with some sort of magic trick
that that is due to a systemic racism as
opposed to saying let's talk about let's
let's talk about black people in class
and let's talk about women in class and
say okay we were we had gotten so close
to where we wanted to be with both of
these with with with with both
demographics if you if for people who
had enough financial stability in the
home in which they grew up that they
were able to take advantage of the
opportunities that Society was busy
providing and and those both of those
but it's but you know both of those are
sliding so let me let me uh rephrase
that and see if I've got it yeah
you had women at every class right
there are women you know uh
foreign
as much as some people would like to
pretend to forget that that's what sex
is you have just as many women and men
at every class basically except in a few
rare cultures doesn't matter right right
uh as for American blacks how many
American black billionaires are there I
don't know but it's going to be a small
fraction of the the billionaire class
it's not going to be equivalent to so
then the race racial ratio here's the
question we had a
increasingly over our lifetimes we
watched racism go from something you
know we were born into an era where you
know there was an echo of of where there
was there was very deep racism left in
the air just prior to the one we were
born into right yeah Martin Luther King
assassinated in 1968.
um so and the significance of that is
not the assassination which uh at least
one court has ruled likely involved the
FBI so it doesn't have to have been a
racist
um
that may have been a political action
but
um you know the point is the Civil
Rights Movement
in which he was deeply involved at that
moment was you know at fever pitch so
well I mean I think it's yeah that then
would be
I think the definition of what people
mean when they say systemic racism like
you know why why would there have been
political impetus to kill uh the
greatest civil rights leader of all time
well the thing is I think I know the
answer individual I think I know the
answer and I think the answer does
involve racism but I don't want to
assume that because the fact is there's
so much money and power at stake in
governmental stuff that who knows what
the actual thought process was
um but the point is the Civil Rights
Movement was uh obviously at its peak
um at that moment and it was that
because there was lots of racism alive
and well but over the course of our
lifetimes that racism uh abated
spectacularly right to the extent that
it is where it was 10 years ago pretty
rare to meet anybody who uh spoke openly
about their racist views by and large
people had gotten over it and they
actually liked the idea that they you
know I will say that this there must be
Regional differences no doubt right no
doubt but in general I mean I don't know
what it was that did it but the fact is
you know
the
cultural mechanisms had spread
everything far and wide in the same way
that people just got very used to gay
you know gay was a big deal when we were
born it was not a big deal as of 10
years ago right it was just a thing um
and that had a lot to do with Freddie
Mercury and it had a lot to do with Will
and Grace and it had a lot to do with uh
you know Elton John and whatever
and so the point is that people just
getting used to this stuff they get over
it and in part they get over it because
once you do as I've said before it's
like giving yourself a raise right yeah
you're paying a cost for your racism
right in part you're paying a cost
because you can't collaborate with
everybody you get rid of it and you just
feel better you worry less you have a
wider range of people that you can make
wealth with so anyway so the point is
you had women at every class much less
so it was much more skewed with respect
to race yep and the difference is that
even if you get rid of the racists right
if you inherit a level of opportunity
you are in a much worse position to
leverage it and so then you can't solve
the problem by imposing right now
requirements around you know things like
quotas right so there's some very
complex question about okay okay all the
racists vanished but I still
I don't have the opportunity with which
to get out of the situation that the
racism created right what do I do with
that what do I do so what I'm pointing
at is like yes we are in a disastrous
phase where we are toying with unmaking
all of the amazing progress that the
West made Against Racism and sexism and
clearly we benefited greatly from
putting this stuff aside the more we put
it aside the better off we did but the
interesting thing is even in
conservative circles right
you find women and men intermingling at
every level of thought and power
that's interesting we actually succeeded
and I think because the women who were
liberated from sexism were in a position
to leverage that Liberation in a way
that uh racially speaking was much less
even
um and so you know we do find many of
the voices who are arguing uh for some
sort of a return in male female space
some sort of a return which I don't
think is possible there's nowhere to go
but nonetheless some of the women who
are making these arguments are highly
accomplished women who are leveraging
the benefits they're the beneficiaries
of many of the societal changes that
they would have us reverse
and that is
um that is staggering to observe and you
know I think
that's a kind of observation that is
made a lot and is often Mis
misattributed but I do think
that as much as there was a lot about
um the changes in expectations around
gender norms and uh and sex roles in
relationships and in society in the
second half of the 20th century uh that
created some problems that most of us
never foresaw
uh the idea that you
you could have benefited greatly from
um
that proportion of those changes that
were extraordinary and and valuable and
be arguing for a return to Trad is
um is striking and it you know it's one
of the things that
causes me to lose hope well but we can
be that any anyone can be so blind to
like what allowed them to be in the
place that they are now speaking to make
sure that what like no one else can come
up behind them and accomplish similar
things but I so I think this is you're
not being dumped into Nazi Twitter
somehow you're not seeing I'm seeing it
yeah I'm not seeing the uh argument for
I guess I have seen an occasional
argument against uh the right of women
to vote but an argument leveled by men
I do not I hear women making an argument
for a return to traditional stuff I hear
lots of them right Mary Harrington
Louise Perry uh Megan Murphy there's
there's a fair amount of this but where
I hear it is not about that's in in in
in their cases that's not who I'm Who
I'm thinking of
um in their cases it I think it's more
about
um
recognizing the value of choice and
returning to it or or creating a world
in which all right if I those are not
three identical thinking people right
but like but there are you know there
was a a moment
um you know maybe a caricature of a
moment in time when
um if you were a middle class American
white woman in 1950 say
um the the thing that you could choose
to do was find a husband and raise a
family and have a nice home and I'm that
is way oversimplified
um but there were plenty of women who
either because they hadn't found a
husband yet or that was just not what
they wanted to do who went out into the
workforce but it was never understood to
be the thing that was what women should
be wanting to do and I think what second
wave feminism did in part and you know I
I have thought of myself as a second
wave feminist even though you know it
came before our time
um was largely freed women from that as
the default expectation
but people argue and I have come around
to this point of view largely that it
went too far in basically demonizing the
thing that hadn't been a choice before
and it hadn't been a choice because it
is what evolution handed to us right
right so it demonized motherhood it
demonized
um being in a partnership with you know
monogamous monogamous relationship
especially with a man it demonized
Desiring to stay home for with your
children yeah if you had chosen to have
to have children and that's crazy right
so we went from you know one restrictive
um one restrictive Paradigm to a
different restrictive Paradigm and there
are many reasonable people arguing for
um both both of those options
ought to be able to be on the table just
as just as options you know anatomical
and physiological limitations aside for
the moment just as is you know there
will be some men not that many probably
but there will be some men who would
prefer to to stay home with their
children and have that be their primary
role when their children are young right
there will be many more women for whom
that would like they would like that to
be their primary role when they're young
but what I'm seeing
increasingly is that is what women want
that is what women want to do like some
women do but a lot of women don't well
and you know
the there are two
different
Foci with respect to uh the Trad women
question yeah
one has to do with uh turning back the
clock on everything
the other has to do with uh fixing what
the sexual Revolution got wrong right
and the problem is that there is you
know
birth control is simultaneously a
tremendous gift
right
one that if you use it irresponsibly can
wreck your civilization but if you
leverage it correctly can liberate women
to do both things right a woman who
wants to have children and to build a
career can now control the timing of her
family and the size of her family and
the point is let me just say that um
often when birth control is invoked here
um it is conflated with hormonal birth
control which it's it's a subset right
they're two different issues and
hormonal birth control has a
particularly
um confusing effect yeah it has it on
the woman who has it right I don't know
and also and everyone around her because
because hormonal differences are
smellable by us at an unconscious level
yeah no I just mean
technologically reliable birth control
right the ability to control when you're
going to produce children allows women
to contribute to many things that they
would have had difficulty contributing
to before because the timing of of uh
the production of a family was going to
be inconvenient and disrupt so the point
is you know this is it's like so many
things right what you have here is a
precious gift and what if you what you
do is you decide hey cool free-for-all
right it screws everything up right
antibiotics for everyone all the time
right yeah mushrooms yay
um yeah so that's that it's one it's one
of these things that you know let's put
it this way
um
this is complex because humans have sex
when I'm not fertile and that that is an
evolutionary adaptation before birth
control
um
so it's not that sex must equal baby
right but not at all the fact that sex
does not equal baby that it has a
relationship building aspect in humans
that is clearly adaptive and is clearly
you know it is about other things that
are important you know they may be
important because of their effect on the
quality of the child you will raise
because a partnership that stays
together and produces full siblings is a
stronger one right but
the point is Recreation is again the
villainous concept you take really
important stuff and you turn it into
Recreation and there's enough telling
which will ruin and again I'm not
arguing that in the case of any of the
things right I'm not arguing that you
shouldn't think you know food is
absolutely delicious that you shouldn't
um you know have you're not speaking
against pleasure like um this this is a
tough a tough one and I think
I'd like to see you or us
drill down on that at some point I don't
know that now is is the right moment but
I don't I don't
I don't think this lands this is going
to land with a lot of people
um because it's it I just don't think
it's quite it's it's not quite fully
formulated and I will say that I was
reading some Wendell Berry again and he
was talking about exactly this in these
words from like the 1970s about
um the move uh to make uh sex
recreational as opposed to
um and
an amazing and you know an amazing part
of a complete relationship in which that
is one of the things that you are
engaging in yeah well for those who are
looking for the delineator between what
you might hear and what I actually mean
I'm talking about the taking of things
that are complex and generative and
turning them into consumer activities
right it's the consumer approach and I'm
not saying that there aren't things that
you should consume right but there's
some things that are just too important
right I would say uh
music sex
food
uh hallucinogenic experiences I'm not
arguing that these things shouldn't be
pleasurable hopefully they will be
overwhelmingly so but
if you come at them as a consumer
you are actually shortchanging yourself
that's what I'm getting at
anyway I will leave it there but um well
it was a lot of topics varied in that
one conversation that was a lot of
topics
[Music]
foreign